thanks to surf shark for sponsoring this
video find out more later in the video
hey 42 here in an effort to get a furry
leg up on our opponents humans have
employed a menagerie of animals in the
theater of war
over two millennia ago carthage used
elephants to defend against roman
expansion in the punic wars
during the second punic war hannibal
even crossed the alps with several
elephants in tow to the great surprise
of rome
it was a feat considered impossible at
the time
during the first world war horses camels
elephants dogs and pigeons saw extensive
action in their roles as munitions
haulers ambulance drivers bomb damage
cleanup squads search and rescue and
message carriers amongst others
for animals and humans alike war is a
time for sacrifice and making do with
the bare necessities
and so that's precisely what the polish
army did in world war ii
by employing an actual bear
not for some creative utilitarian
purpose
nope
as a genuine soldier
in 1942 polish soldiers who'd recently
been released from soviet prison camps
were forced to evacuate war-torn central
europe by taking an arduous journey for
iran with the goal of reaching the
safety of british forces stationed in
palestine
but just outside of hamadan in the
northwest of iran
they stumbled across a young shepherd
boy at first glance he wasn't unusual
but what did strike them is odd was his
backpack
which was moving and wriggling around
as though it was alive which it turned
out it was because there was a bear cub
inside
now iran is an exotic country offering
many incredible sights but even for iran
in the middle of the desert this was a
little strange
it turns out the poor cub had been
recently orphaned after its parents were
shot by hunters
and this young shepherd boy had taken
pity on him
if you love travelling then you'll love
the fastest and easiest vpn surf shark
did you know surf shock also helps you
to avoid price discrimination based on
your location
so you can save money on plane tickets
and car rentals whilst traveling
surfshock runs on any device anywhere
and it's packed full of features such as
industry-leading uncrackable encryption
ip and dns leak protection
an internet kill switch if your vpn
drops out and 24 7 customer support by
using surfsharkvpn you can stay
anonymous and secure online personally i
use surfshock to watch netflix content
from other countries such as the us it's
usually blocked here in the uk
it's so easy all you have to do is
switch over your location setting and
there you have it instant access to your
favorite programs importantly surfshark
maintains a strict no logs policy and
their network of
3200 servers and over 65 countries runs
completely on ram so they can't log your
data even if they want to by using the
code 42 you'll benefit from an 83
percent discount plus three extra months
for free
all you have to do is click the special
link in the description below don't miss
out guys
despite its sad start in life the cub a
syrian brown bear was so playful that
the soldiers just had to adopt him the
boy was willing to hand over the bear
but for a price
the soldiers being war refugees and all
weren't exactly brimming with money
yet they handed over much of what they
had some persian coins chocolate a swiss
army knife and a tin of beef
which sounds like a good deal to me as
it did to the boy
the soldiers then donated the bear to
their unit the 22nd artillery supply
company he promptly named him voytek
which means joyful warrior owing to his
playful nature
wojtek became a mascot a pet
and in a strange way just one of the
boys
initially he had trouble swallowing so
the soldiers filled empty vodka bottles
with condensed milk to feed vojtec as
one would feed a baby with a bottle but
before long a growing vojtech had moved
on to stronger stuff and he enjoyed
eating the camp supply of fruit honey
syrup and even beer
that's right being surrounded by
soldiers all day certainly had its
effects for better or for worse
as the men gathered around the campfire
in the evenings they would pass their
bottles to vojtec who would happily
knock back the booze like winnie the
pooh attacking a honey jar spiked with
methamphetamine
and yes in case you were wondering he
did drink it straight out the bottle
just like his human comrades
he was also partial to the odd cigarette
although his method of consuming them
was a bit
unusual
for starters he would turn his nose up
at an unlit cigarette demanding they
were always lit before being passed to
him
then he would take just one puff
and promptly swallow it whole
shockingly the soldiers obviously didn't
consider this behavior too odd or
you know stop and think that it probably
wasn't a good idea to feed a bear
alcohol and cigarettes literally then
the soldiers took things up a level by
having wrestling matches with wojtek
though rather predictably he usually won
resulting in scratches and torn clothing
for his challengers
is it just me who's wondering how hitler
ever successfully invaded a country full
of men who wrestled bears for fun
anyway voy tech fit in well at the 22nd
artillery supply company
too well in fact
at least for a bear aside from spending
his days necking bottles of beer
wrestling and smoking he also marched
with the soldiers and even learned to
salute yeah thank goodness the nazis
didn't lay their hands on him first
otherwise we might have ended up with a
very offensive bear
just in case wojtek wasn't fitting in
well enough with his fellow mammals
already
he also enjoyed gathering around the
campfire in the evening i'm not sure if
he had any stories to tell and sleeping
in the soldier's tents
which sounds rather cute but surely
waking up in the middle of the night to
find a bear spooning you
would be pretty terrifying
and what about the smell
well luckily for the soldiers wojtek was
a very clean bear indeed and he
thoroughly enjoyed taking daily showers
he was even capable of turning the taps
on all by himself
in fact voytek's hygiene habits were a
little too intense he spent so long in
the shower he'd often leave the soldiers
without any hot water
something had to be done and so the
doors to the showers were fit with a
lock
but that didn't stop wojtek from
checking it every day just in case one
of his forgetful friends had left it
open
and sure enough one fortuitous day
wojtek went to check on the shower doors
and were surprised to find them slightly
ajar
with no luck in sight but he could sense
something wasn't right and headed inside
cautiously
suddenly a loud scream erupted from the
shower stalls it turned out to be an
arabian spy who was hiding in the
showers startled by the screams the
soldiers quickly came to the rescue
detaining the insurgent and questioning
him
luckily for them he was so bleeding
terrified after being surprised by a god
damn bear that he was a complete blabber
mouth
can you blame him
he even let slip that there was an
impending raid on their position
wojtek was duly rewarded with a long hot
shower
that year the polish army traveled all
over the middle east with their bare in
toe but in 1943 they were drafted to
italy where there was one slight issue
the bigwigs at the top had somehow come
to the conclusion that it wasn't the
best idea for a professional army to
have such a grisly companion knocking
around
war being quite a serious matter and all
i beg to differ he certainly played his
part with that spy
and then there was the small master that
it was forbidden for pets to come aboard
the british transport ship due to take
the soldiers to italy
but voytech's loyal family who'd raised
him from a weak hub
weren't going to have any of that
so after some persuasion vojtech was
officially drafted into the polish army
as a private
along with his own pay book rank and the
serial number
he was just as much a soldier as any of
the other men
no longer a pet there was now nothing
stopping him from catching the boat to
italy and joining his friends on the
front line
and so he did
and a special wooden crate was
constructed for his passage
as it turned out wojtek was more than
just a mascot and a companion
in his new official role he served
diligently and actually aided in the
fight against germany
in the battle of monte casino in 1944
wojtek watched on as he saw the soldiers
repeatedly lifting crates and ammunition
to the front lines
wanting to prove his metal and earn his
stripes wojtek of his own volition
began carrying the 100-pound creative
artillery shells to the soldiers
he carried boxes that usually required
four men all by himself
which he would then stack onto a truck
in thanks for his service wojtek was
promoted to the rank of corporal and the
depiction of a bear carrying artillery
shells was adopted as the official
emblem of the 22nd artillery supply
company in 1947 the company in which he
dutifully served was demobilized
and wojtek was taken under the care of
edinburgh zoo at first he was placed in
a bearing closure but it quickly became
apparent that voitech didn't actually
get along with other bears
like at all
he probably thought they were a little
too bear-like for him he had spent his
entire life swigging lager with the lads
to be fair
so he was given his own enclosure where
he became quite the celebrity
polish soldiers who'd served with wojtek
often visited him and against zoo policy
would jump over the fence and into the
enclosure for a quick wrestle
they would bring him beer and cigarettes
lit of course which he would promptly
puff and then gunk
vojtech died in 1963 at the ripe old
bear age of 21
which considering his lifestyle and diet
was pretty good going for a syrian bear
and what a life he had
today his legacy is commemorated by
monuments in both krakow anzagon in
poland and edinburgh and duns in
scotland he was a companion and friend
to many and above all the best goddamn
nazi fighting bear the world has ever
seen period
thanks for watching
do you really enjoy my content but you
literally can't be asked to use your
eyes
then you're in luck because you can now
listen to the new random interesting
facts podcast with me 42 available on
youtube spotify apple podcast or
wherever you get your podcast you'll
find a link to it in the description
below check it out today and give your
eyes a break you're welcome